the jurgen experience i came back
alienated and numb i didn't come back as
a protester
but uh confused how did you feel about
that
with my father oh fighting with your
father sure of course i gave him lsd one
time ever
did on purpose did he know yeah didn't
he know you were given no he didn't know
i'd give it to him but he knew that he
was on something you know
[Laughter]
how did you do that i just was just
living in his coffee no it is scotch ah
even better how much
quite a bit he was strong though
yeah he handled it he's drinking he
drank he drank
whiskey every day of his life so yeah he
was a tough guy but he was great he was
like
swaying to the music and oh wow i mean
sex fantasy
wow did you tell him about it afterwards
like
no actually but over the years we
he knew i kind of after a while you
figured it out i guess
i was a long-haired wild kid you know
right right talking
black talk to him did you feel like you
had to do it
because like you you knew what kind of
an impact it would have on him that
opens up i was fighting with him no we
were fighting about the war fighting
about everything
like i just didn't like his ideas and
wanted to destroy his mindset
oh wow his mindset was okay we this
vietnam is a mess but
his mindset was but we can learn from it
we can get armaments we're going to
build up our knowledge for the next war
that was his thinking
right see he came out of that generation
of world war ii
he was his father was wiped out in the
in 29
and his first job was as a floor walker
he didn't have anything
he worked his way up on wall street a
very hard worker
research in the back offices so when
with war was the war second world war
was the
highlight of his life he says he comes
back from the war and america faced
this problem you know what are we going
to do with all these men and now we got
the women working
how are we going to employ all these
people everybody seemed to be scared of
another depression they thought we're
going back into that so
there was this militarized economy that
we had and they kept going
it basically kept going and built up by
we it ended in 45 by 1950 51 we were
back in korea
where we were building up again so the
whole concept of an enemy was
important to the american economy and uh
the the soviet union of course fit the
bill although they were our ally in
world war ii and
did most of the fighting they became our
our biggest enemy right away
right away there was no hesitation about
us it was
often a political decision you know to
have an enemy
to create fear and to keep the
militarized economy that we have
and it got eisenhower talked about it he
was the one who built it up the most but
we're getting ahead of ourselves no no
no we're not i mean it's fine
um but my father came from that
generation and
he believed firmly that russia was
really invading our country threatening
it
uh they were in our schools they were in
our state department
i mean he wasn't joe mccarthy but there
was a lot of that mentality nixon was
like that yeah
hoover was pushing it and i grew up
terrified i grew up terrified that dad
why
why why why why do we let the russians
do that that kind of mentality of being
besieged
and so my father and i fought a lot as
you can imagine
because you know i got kicked out of
he'd take me to a restaurant i'd
i'd have an american tie it was made out
of american flag right
and the restaurant owner would kick me
out because uh you know he thought it
was disrespectfully
an ex-marine that's interesting you can
have an american flag anything now and
you're respectful
that's weird like you get an american
flag hat or a t-shirt and oh come on
this was a different world this is still
the uh this is the height of the
you know still the 70s the older people
were
were offended by that yeah that's it's
interesting how that shifted right like
now the more american flags the better
on everything socks underwear nothing
nothing is respectable
yeah it's different it's so yeah it's
really weird it's kind of been
bastardized
[Applause]
you